just call my face yeah and now an
adjutant what's up look let's just put
hot sauce in here see what happens all
right perfect done I love this game
already hello random in cancer I'm your
host Don you are joined by Nick hides
identity my friends from London explain
to good people who you are and who you
work for
I would have seen it who review hardware
and and phones and fax machines love ya
CFO or did we make you up I totally
forgot the Mike makeover sorry my babe
alright so for the folks at home would
you like to introduce yourself again pax
was a long weekend guys I don't that I
think I might be still drunk it didn't
have to be over good am I doing this
right
I think that's perfect especially cuz
the wire is in full view is it obscuring
my amazing wild stallions t-shirt that's
pretty good while stallions no ban from
Bill and Ted's okay excellent adventure
I should have known that how did you
know know that because I'm an awful
person
dude you're also the person possibly the
best April Fool's joke of all time yet
somehow that got currency again you
might have seen it recently on the
internet man arrested at Large Hadron
Collider yeah arrested yeah which he
wrote in 2010 and I had two people
mentioned to me over the weekend in
Boston from two completely different
areas of my life it's incredible like
that that thing has come around the
internet at least five times yeah
and people think it's real yes pretty
good we're not here to talk about that
you were on my friends wait do you want
to explain Who I am again because I was
not miked up I think maybe it's a it's a
missed that now you were he works for
scene at UK OH
they review phones and stuff what are
you the global copy editor global copy
chief chief chief anyway you're here
because last weekend we announced on the
next big game and the intern also
announced that a Sid Meier
that's how you say things I've been
saying mirror my entire life and I also
pronounced the word genre as jr. for the
first six years of my life reading PC
gamer not the first six years of my life
wasn't being PC gamer when I was one and
well fluorosis which is a weird intro
yeah yeah they announced them beyond
Earth which is the I guess spiritual
successor to Alpha Centauri which is my
fear axis is game in 1999 oh there it is
and there it is so good that you were
annexed well you've played this game
quite almighty's a long time ago I
played this game very little and it was
about 15 years ago well you missed out
Danny so it's a bona fide a classic okay
well let's just jump right in alright
and have a look at it and this is
available on GOG calm for about 6 bucks
at this and the expansion your own wit
expansion was called alien something I
think a invasion or infestations
crossfire thank you Benito you know is
also a massive office and Tory buff but
unfortunately we need him to do
technical things today so yeah let's
just I'm gonna go start game enough
quits nourish here we can pick huge map
of climate the map of planners customize
a rather map and make around the map
must be big make a random map
tiny pad small standard large huge well
we want to actually see some of the
players don't we yes let's go small
small my citizen difficulty level
specialist librarian or thinker you're
like remedial let's go citizen okay is
that good gameplay experience as well
idea it's all the same like you as far
as I remember the difficulty level is I
think AI yeah be AI and how hard the
aliens attack us okay no specialists are
that's standard rules are current rules
standard rules I love no way we're like
blocking wood I wonder what that even is
current rules
standard rules standard anyone you know
yeah if you're in the chat as well Nick
is looking at all sounds like a
60-second delay so they're talking about
[ __ ] that happened ages ago okay let's
go standard rules alright can I move
this thing I can't okay
okay this is when it gets weird and
Spacey so this is for those who don't
know Sid Meier was making it clearly
made all these civilization games this
is kind of like a sieve in space yeah so
in sieve one of the standard victory
things that you can do is make a big
rocket and go to the Earth's nearest
neighbor near Alpha Centauri which is a
start any thank you and in this game you
play as one of the leaders of the humans
that have survived on that ship in a row
and arrived at Alpha Centauri okay and I
believe in the fiction the captain of
that ship has been assassinated by
someone and the spaceship is split into
seven faction oh okay and they all land
on the planet at the same time and they
want to run this new world their way
they all have their own philosophy okay
and that translates in the game to lots
of bonuses classic doom you know it
wears like three houses looking for like
it is a bit lower yeah and they've got
the wrong kind of ones like super into
tech one's kind of like yes more
biologic it's very much influenced by
that kind of hard sci-fi sort of fiction
so we've got here we've got a lady
Deirdre Skye or I guess Deirdre did you
hear from the she's the green so I
guessing she's like super into recycling
yeah the despot human hive so he'll get
bonuses to like starting new cities okay
and his cities will grow quicker this
guy likes I think merging a technology
or something the scientist that kind of
trad I could damien procs or zakharov i
have tasted the fruit we have the Mogul
here and look boot Kate Morgan
the survivalist the fundamentalist and
humanitarian you should go for
I like the scientist I like him too he's
got that's you know ii like a cool old
70s dude yeah okay the substructure
along three columns Sakharov this is
infinitely tool used to call people in
our space but this guy is a dude so
Danny our face is a Corral our space
okay oh we can change gender oh you can
change everything
whoa oh cool because okay because
there's loads of fiction bits in the
game right and it'll put the right word
Oh brilliant so instead of brilliant
let's do sexy description gender legend
what am i did a University of the abyss
fine come on come on
it's a crevasse face nospace just caught
my face yeah and now an adjective
what's what let's just put hot sauce in
here see what happens right perfect done
I love this game already
iris face a new era is struggle of
opportunity awaits you the UN starship
unity has arrived at Alpha Centauri
system after a 40-year long voyage all
contact with earth has been lost
alpha captain Garland's assassination
very good oh I didn't mean by an unknown
assailant the crew mutinied and split
into factions in the insane conflict
some seized control of the unities
colony pods you are now shape you now
shape the destiny of your bought sauce
faction it's made planet ball
alright let's do it oh look at that but
sauce look at that check out that
animation what are we gonna call the
base but base thank you I'm really happy
that you're on I'm going on the horse
with the pod here so to speak alright
okay your calling is crash-landed on
Alpha Centauri its stores have been used
to found your first base what base you
can here's the sketch patrol unit which
can now activate so is now active to
explore the surrounding area it can also
be used for
fence if necessary okay this is your
should we take the tour - okay let's do
it
the unit's the chances are people
watching this have never played this
game or haven't dated in a while yeah 15
years ago the unit's standard status box
blinks when it's ready to move for this
use this sketch patrol to explore okay
Chris use the arrow keys to go or to
move around whoa Wow okay this game
looks great
on modern computers as well because we
Benito figured out that if you type in
direct draw equals zero into one of the
text files or any files it just does it
to the resolution of whatever computer
you have and he also found that every
single piece of text in this game is
based in a text file so you can just go
in there and edit it coal sale amazing
scripts for the game
which is pretty good so you could make
every word in the game but yeah right so
you should do that we should create our
home laughs I forgot the play I would
think so your first job is to use your
scare patrol to explore the area around
your base okay so what do we do alright
so that's that's that's your base screen
that's showing you how much so you've
got a population of one great and it's
how are we gonna procreate well you need
some food lots of masturbating yeah
wishing for the best support pretty sure
that's what NASA recommends okay
discover activates the governor Explorer
okay that's like a pre-set way of
running your base Oh
so build discover explore yeah so if you
select discover it'll automatically tune
that base to make Scout units or you can
just do it your own way you can hit yeah
I want to do our own way set your own
governor settings for a bud base okay
okay so what's reset this one is build
build yeah
it doesn't make any difference because
you can't like you see the where the
resources one one yes that's the NIT
that's just a that's the the best you
can get at the moment I'll give you two
we need to build a worker thingy to come
in and clear out some of this so that
red stuff I think is alien goop this red
slows you down
how can you need to we need to get rid
of that somehow so how do I move this
dude don't you can you use the numbers
you know yoga or just click oh [ __ ]
alright it'll be easier for you to move
unit to here resources so these poor
things think of you stuff we have
discovered the materials podge from the
unity so this is something that crashed
off the planet so the unity was the big
ship right that's split apart
okay turn complete press enter for next
time superior training and superior
weaponry have effect on overall military
strength it's poison well trained well
equipped troops can stand up to many
more times this is a lot of moisture
than linear Kate oh sweet nice twenty
thirty 2103 both sauce workers on their
Provos ours face they'll their first
facility on planet up but base nice
we've ruined this whoa that's kind of
cool
oh I see alright so as you get more of
these landmark things that now here on
your own personal monument thing right
okay
oh look that that must be like a um
because I've best been gasps okay so I
clicked that and now we're now we're
producing way more so oh wow I guess the
diamond thing is production green is
food so we're not going to grow as
quickly so what do you do always slack
on things to assign them yeah so you've
got we've got one see where it says one
we've got like one guy and yeah and he
can go and do one he can work one
resource so it's probably best colony
pod we don't actually want that see the
funny thing is whenever I played these
games like the Forex guys I always I
always come at them from like an because
they're isometric from like an age of
empires rise of Nations like I'll pay
the crap out of those types of games no
more and this is like this is one step
removed from that you are not telling
people where to go and attack units and
you know this is turn-based it is a
bearish like this is almost like middle
management video games where you're like
telling people what to do rather than
doing them yourself yeah and I don't
have that much experience in this time
together no here we go this symbol
represents abundant mineral sources if
you have a base within two squares it
will be able to produce additional
minerals especially if you build a mine
here we've Mineworkers wheat sown Aries
in so if we go back to our stage that
you're going to come and shut down our
mind so if you so this is what we're
building at the moment its colony pod
which i think is like a settler unit
okay I'd build another city but if we
change you clicked change these are the
only things that we can build at them
out because I've discovered how to make
a worker unit right to work that
resource and build a mine gotcha okay
how did you like them no no I don't know
let's look in manual
and what do you think HQ social
engineering so I worked for Hitler this
is what we want that's exactly what we
want and you and I'm gonna take this
sorry I'm not reaching for you peanuts
that's it's what we want the new I'm the
new world order to be oh really
yeah we want to be new Hitler's right
yeah exactly
yeah but Hitler's bought Hitler Butler's
it's ass basically ah damn
alright okay so these in which areas are
scientists focused the research focus
nice nuclear it makes discoveries in
that area more likely discover advance
of knowledge Kalla nation yet we won
that okay right yeah but I'm guessing it
just you just have to wait a bit do your
turn cycles there must be a better way
of doing I'm moving the eyes out of that
does that I say did
oh it's not like on yeah okay so you're
going to dude with the curse P this
isn't this is a trip that especially as
left her maybe force him over its ideas
turn
energy pairs your research labs have
helped your researchers discover and
exploit new technologies you guide their
research by controlling the field in
which they study thank you yeah we know
about that
oh we just did this all right so Toria
you just trying to get ahead of us okay
cause we're so pro at this video game
yeah
Centauri ecology oh now we can behind
soil and the rich yellow sunlight
careful I'm telling for Mia that's what
we need so wait for that colony thing
ladies Tara for comparative biology oh
hello Jesus the weather paradigm
increases terraforming speed oh this is
a project okay right so these are secret
projects are like wonders of the world
remember that incest in Alpha Centauri
they're called secret projects and so
this would take a hundred and eighty
units of production source and it would
give us these bonuses I love how they've
put them production so they managed to
homogenize all the parts of society to
just be production production and food
and sexy times lady Deirdre Skye is into
this one apparently she's being happy
we've attained technologies which allow
us to design many units would you care
to see new units yes yes okay oh this is
so cool this is one of the best bits
about the game
okay the design workshop you can
customize your own units oh wow it gives
you a load of units but you can also use
like the chassis you know can you click
on that as our different ones we have
different ones now
okay hang on oh nice we're just deleted
the tutorial whoops
see I do remember it getting very very
unwieldy the depth of these games and
the lack of giving a crap about learning
all this information yeah
this is something I kind of miss like I
guess that's probably why I like games
like Dark Souls doing that it's just
like just deal without your video games
yeah and like I got the UH I got a lot
of this one like XCOM as well oh hello
okay so we got a faster Scout unit
what's that okay so these are its stats
whatever they mean like wait special
ability can we do any of those yet no
okay
you have any special abilities yes we
named as the but Rover can we rename us
yes we can't say this is do anyway this
is the only contribution I have to this
episode of item again who should we -
both
if you're felling it will one tea and
I've kind of like that all right we're
doing that yeah whoa-oh-oh scientists
discover Centauri ecology oh okay this
is another side of the thing okay so
this means that we're the first faction
of the seven to actually discover
something great
take that you other six Jokers
oh and then you can see so that it gives
you a little badge on you on your plinth
mmm so we've got that one and then and
you can see it later so that probably
took them three weeks to make this bit
yep so where the turns whereas the
cement of the turns isn't based on the
amount of like overall turns you have
it's based on the individual terms of
each unit
we've only got that so that's the same
thing at the moment yeah and I got one
unit so let's go this way
oh hello the thick Zen no fungus
obstructs your unit some time to take
several turns to enter is oh no fungus
square okay so that's the alien
life-form that we've come across and
it's basically a big red mushroom okay
that's how exciting this game is when it
comes to alien units but later on in my
favorite more exciting okay
so there we go how do you see I'm so
mission year 2010 yeah 21:10 sorry it's
magic voice Danny Jeff if they're like
yeah we got there who's but based on
what I'm always already doing it great
and we've got another unit sweet amazing
where we put that then alright okay so
that's good so when this builds in for
turn so it can go and make a mine or
probably clear out some of this Zen o40
fungus and because we we're not growing
see growth stagnant so this isn't
getting bigger so we're not getting more
people take growing is that like the the
society yes so the population of our
new it's a still only one person it's
the one unit yeah it's just one guy but
man but now we've got a butt colony
colony pod which represents the
equipment and manpower to found a new
base remove it to an appropriate spot
this is the one indicated by the second
all right so the canoe is telling us
what a good place to put okay I disagree
because these things up here unlike
special resources so I'm gonna play them
up there
I love hair like there is this
disconnect between like the population
being one is ridiculous already because
how could you procreate but then also
you're gonna make another city you only
got one person why don't you make
another city
it's like let's make me sense is like
one unit of people stop me and psycho so
a minor breakthrough peated lee that's
good tin foil we can make foil yes
finally my mies can be things prepared
better I think that's a [ __ ] but I felt
this was a lesson he must learn early a
foil in troop transport so that did you
hear that that was that was a bit of
voice acting so when you discover
something an actor reads this bit of
text out which is kind of you know 9
tonight tonight it's pretty hairy 19 for
context that's like look 9 is a year
after half-life boom came out 99 is dear
I think quake 3 came out I'm done in a
tournament yeah
so yeah just in the brother it's also AB
99 I want to say that's what I mean if I
came out definitely for era yeah no
sorry
oh yeah just for alright we have
obtained tension is there Octavia sure
nothing oh it's a troop transport okay
well we don't have any hovercraft so
that can go across water
oh yeah even in in the new world there
are oceans exactly the same as ours
alright what's that thing
Oh No is that worm oh no it's gonna hit
our colony thing to worm this is Doug
dune yes
is a spice one I think it's a psychic
worm oh and see formas look at that we
could make see it's a terraforming so
you can mine it see you I see you Conley
very Chinese yes yes you can you can
make us a city in the sea oh my god this
game is mindworms my grams Danny it's
now underwater
it's not just mushrooms one of planet's
most carrots called planet can appear
suddenly especially in there fungus
squares
mindworms viciously attacked settlements
so if your mind thinking limbo toad
yes there hypnotoad x' but they like do
you remember in civilization used to get
barbarians yeah they would come out of
the wilderness and attack your cities
douchebags these are alien barbarians
this okay so their mind worms Danny I
may be being very reductive yeah but you
remember and XCOM enemy unknown or UFO
defenses it was no no do you remember
Tara from the deep yes remember how that
was basically the exact same game except
they just arranged a bunch of textures
and change the buncha nations what are
you insane us yeah and the tank wasn't
under water tank and the aliens really
yeah this to me is very similar it is
basically Sumerians will can't be on the
planet in its place it's basically a mod
of civilization - yeah and have you seen
the have you seen all the stuff they've
released around the new game no I
haven't seen all of it as Alex big game
GameSpot's I think there's one
screenshot that they've released so far
and basically it's this but with
civilization five hexes right okay it's
brilliant it's gonna be amazing
I can't wait alright so how could a fair
access I'd like delivering on like
childhoods re-imaginings of like the
best games they have just like between
they are the best the XCOM remake yeah
which was incredible and they actually
didn't make the original XCOM
it was Microprose which sid meier
actually has worked for and then he left
and this was the first game that they
made as Firaxis no Sid Meier's
Gettysburg
oh really looked it up just before yeah
really was that apparentiy that was on
there for actors as well okay maybe not
maybe it was like an engine testing I
don't I never played that this is called
the zone of control I did man this is
stupid worm is screwing up my colony
plans hey what happened Ellie's around
oh god he's surrounded okay so we're
gonna have to you can't get it that
square because they're warm yeah
three killed murdered the rope worm do
you have to have an army for that so the
colony doesn't have any weapons right
that's a problem
anything yeah get back again so I need
my Scout to come and kill up half you've
any questions as well feel free to send
them in and we've got a good nice core
group of people who were kind of like
you're interested in yeah that's good
there's Nick as welcome seem at UK just
allows you fair if they have a lot of
people in chat before they played the
game oh yeah let us know if you new to
this or not have you got any tips where
should we send our colony pod so there's
this thing is gonna kill the colony pod
that's got all our hopes and dreams we
need to remove itself to try and see
what more squares there are south
oh okay coming down I'm trying to be the
best way to move it around I don't think
it can it can go long as each turn like
four months or something you months
exist on Alpha Centauri I think it's a
year okay Jesus that's quite a lot again
it doesn't make a lot of sense so I
can't go southeast
I can only go I got off super-mega loser
thinks these aren't texting oh my god
there's another arm you're kidding me
mind will boil spots I mean if I come
back
whoa in saikhan buy weapons and armor
strikes are ignored and the attacker is
given three to two damage on land
advantage morale level becomes quite
important in Saigon but wow this is
complicated
hello this is deafening very early so
this is a different mechanic to that in
civilization is this or do they just
rename the car did you just see what
happen what happened the there's nothing
to do with what happened just there
right this is we just died a university
has been eradicated
wait where the [ __ ] is our city gone do
they just kid our city and our dude did
the mic worms just kill her entire
complex what happen what happened it pop
a bit of the ground or something I have
a look in the video I know it's already
happened alright well we don't want to
go down there but I've got as it maybe
started the game again because we were
so bad so I've got all these units we
don't have a city though and they said
the University have been eradicated
which is like an end of end of games
right it's like for a faction take the
Town Hall I think maybe they're giving
us a second chance maybe because you had
your dude outside maybe but it looked
like there is splatted all right that's
yeah it's just probably Bayes net build
see enter a name for your new base what
base to perfect it looks just like the
old bug face there's something funny
when it's Provost our space yeah all
right okay so this place is a bit
different so we've got a lot of we've
got a lot of food here yes this C
resource we've got space fish but we
don't have much production so that's
gonna be difficult in this okay so the
end there like as you are playing
through this what is the end goal is it
to destroy the other factions ah good
question Danny okay so this is an
example of the Forex strategy genre or
engineer as you might have called it and
in a Forex you've got four ways to win
you can kill everyone else you can have
an economic victory like basically you
have so much more money than everyone
else that you've won you can have a
science victory where you reach the end
of the technology tree and usually build
something before everyone else
watch it thanks race kind of stuff
exactly and what's the other one both
what's the fourth X what's the fourth X
before we go to break
we've got like combat economy science
diplomatic yeah right so make everyone's
a break all right cool satori in another
couple of minutes in like 30 seconds so
I mean hopefully we're gonna figure out
what which way we're gonna [ __ ] take
over this goddamn planet
yeah we just called planner see in a
second how to pronounce genre yeah
junior alright thanks for bearing with
us random encounters back here we've got
a Sid Meier's Alpha Centauri nickyta
seen at UK your hello and in charge of
the case here let's go let's do a bit of
exploring let's see what's in this
what else around map what should we make
Danny let's make I love the weather
paradigm with such a great another scout
maybe so let's make a ship okay so this
is a gun a gun foil it's like a hydro
scouting unit great it's a dude on top
of jet ski so that'll make it'll take
eight turns because our but base two
does not have much in the way of
production option oh cool cool but we've
got a bunch of other units I think
because the game was being kind to us
after this faintness on any difficulty I
think so oh that's what I wrote it is
yeah yes you are right
so this is a land foil let's see this is
a former so that's like a worker unit
okay and it can go and do stuff like
murder
[ __ ] worms no that can't it's not a
combat unit let's yeah do it go see what
we've got another colony guy let's move
him this is only one trying to go
planting forest is an excellent way of
increasing resources fire squares
provide a limited supply of nutrients
minerals and energy than a square cool
oh so this is like geo forming so we're
adapting the world to suit our needs can
we make a forest full of naked ladies
and also dudes but they're in a
different Camargo forest so it's not
weird we can make a forest of butts
about forests there may be lots of dude
butts
terraform no again oh cool there we go
cost I can make a mine or forest let's
do a forest suite so I'll take the four
turns and that one should I go and kill
that one can that
sket do it probably not you probably die
I've never need to see what's up yeah go
on are just you know just okay let's get
them set then I don't want to die well
that won't just flew halfway across the
yeah they meet in it I remember this
they move faster in the red bits right
because that's their like mushroom
territory you can move quicker they go
cause they're hot dog bun shrooms yep
risk him yeah that's risky
okay so but janky animation meant that
he needs more turns worth of movement to
get through that okay yeah just like
mine Durham boy spotted near - for God's
sake whoa what's going on there [ __ ] was
that that what I think that was a scout
unit from another civilization Oh
getting eaten by them service what's a
line is that our like fog of war this
thing here I think that's a border with
the next Oh
the next colony that's not yet met let's
send the Scout down there and try and
see if we can if you can discover a
better way for you to view those people
want to happen sister well-governed city
becomes a possibility no right truly
where psych not sure but if Latos here
but what's great variation fillings
reduces number of drawings so that's
like radiuses unhappy girl inc okay
drones isn't like obama no ok or amazon
delivering things okay it's not we don't
have like pool cork operatives no not
yet no that's in the tech tree
alright and what is that gun world of
warcraft
what's that doctrine
all right well first we'll figure that
out I'll probably tell us so nothing is
perfect yes you know that's a no fungus
right SID
what is that thing again that's our
colony okay yeah put it there yeah
perfect
no no we need it to go a bit further
away from the but based - okay so safe
yeah perfect
that'll do all right Oh we built our
forest excellent let's build a mine sure
mine yeah we got those ocean christos
forest expense but based in crash forest
because its proximity to fertile land
another since it be an excellent
location but I see that you're right I'm
so good at it to build a base here press
the B key or select construct my heavy
yes yeah yeah but base junk base when I
go to the front a garage joke base yeah
alright so this is why taken from them
you idiot because I hope they don't
because that's what the worm lives
earlier so you put it there you get
three oh wow you can move this as you
put it there you get one from the sea
and two from the mineral analysis they
recognize a good these water crystals
that's better okay and then what should
we build here see former yeah got our
gun yeah yes c4 move because we want to
improve that resource perfect
how many turns until we get that oh oh
the forest grew the unit said before I
screw the forest grew on its own oh so
we don't want to move that okay and we
want to let's put a mine over here is
that kind of stopped like the worms
getting to us and stuff we slowed enough
ah good question we also know the
foundation out there are we getting
loads of stuff from research because the
thing that's on an easy mode as well
watch me have whatever you want she was
through the planet you yeah and oh I see
so you know how I squared has like a
project one extra tell was a talent
talents educators oh right okay yeah
that's talent like I'm able to balance a
bottom edge
yeah you know exactly like that Benny
yeah you're a real talent talents are
preposterous course Oh prosperous this
is why I'm a video man mm-hmm it's
hardcore as many times as drones no
drone okay so this is very similar to
civilization it could produce two
additional nutrients if it had a farm
but we don't want a farm
I want a mine I want to explore getting
sure we need right I'm a patient yes
yeah I got 20 minutes oh okay all right
completely undefended mmm operator mind
one yeah we know that's why it's called
but base to production complete [ __ ] we
built the tight I like that on spec did
someone either deliver it's it's just a
regular like sieve boat but with [ __ ]
ladies space laser guns the least
futuristic looking space-boat I've ever
seen that's great how 1999 is it that
something like that seafaring foil
things are Harper cracks like in 1999
there was nothing more futuristic than
hovercraft
isn't that what you're cooking let it go
look we're exploring all explored the
crap out of this place
holy [ __ ] this are they're gonna move
our there and space or sea worms
yes so you see these that thing there
yeah that's the equivalent of the red
thing but in the sea okay so you will
move
turns out oh hello some sort of a
delicious crystal yeah keep going down
that's the quickest way to go oh yeah
the symbol represents abundant energy if
you have a base of into squares it'll
put it all right so we need to build a
base like there there or there is this a
very like an overly island-based part of
it looks like it doesn't it we're not
and much like save like there is a good
degree of yeah you know variety in terms
of it yeah like an archipelago map oh
hello yes we want that that that's one
of those resource pods that fell from
the sky sweet no it's not that's like a
scene mind room I guess no you just
drove straight into the math of oh let's
go no wait that's anyway no I want to
shoot it yeah amazing our gunfire unit
has performed admirably it's been
promoted excellent great I didn't know
otherwise it was the big lasers no that
was the psychic we had a psychic mind
war with the sea worm did you not get
that from that amazing animation I love
this game the unit has become damaged
and come back damaged in its code but
don't burn her damage moving into a base
and have it skip its turn yell I just so
so if you can also conduct fill repair
but slow the order that's fine it's half
it's okay we can carry on
there are only two ways in which we can
exact words of the human element of
experience with the concepts of its own
alright let's make experience possible
whoa whoa that's sweet neck tattoo you
got secrets of the human brain
look we're really adding up our on we're
artists I thought that got destroyed
when blood based I take I see but the
new one yeah if our society come on
trade networks are wrong can we send
that the probe to be seized
Oh collective consciousness by decision
bro yeah a crucial point in your bus
Provost our space only purpose its life
its probe team it's just a dude with a
suitcase presumably full of probes yeah
that's his name
we named why does he have a fishing
reactor on his back because there's a
lot of inconsistency in a oh sorry yeah
Rover probe team anal probe team did it
save that was it too long was it too
long I don't know
rename again maybe you didn't apply it
right no that was it was it there all
right hit okay
they supply our interns at unit time
it's gonna be way too [ __ ] option
yeah this is really confusing I didn't
paint so let's build some pyro Vox one
thanks for watching alright let's go
into enemy territory and see what's
going on
heading south any yeah James oh no I
built another gun for without actually
meaning to I'll send him that way then
okay but let me just so you keep making
the kind which we make protein probe
tape the only way we can excite as a
society is if we stick things in other
societies butts production company
hopefully it's some sort of alien
creature we can have a mind war with oh
cool I bet my remember mine so if you
look at this 1 to 100 it's not as good
as a forest that was stupid didn't the
earth let's go down here oh that's that
former we ordered great let's change
this again what do we want to build here
see colony pod I wanna go see yes
Atlantis here we go oh no not here
because this place has got rubbish
production reduction 21 turns yeah oh no
it doesn't nope no cuz it's got the
thing next to it yeah no it's good it's
21 turns every time you tap or is it
every time you hit enter it's a bit
opaque isn't it yes every time that
you're all your units have run out of
stuff to do okay do you have to enter
every time than then where does it seem
to reset it does it automatically but
you can probably change it in the menu a
tariff or cultivate kelp farm construct
mining particle space cap construct
title harness I like tidal hard do you
have any idea where near these do let's
go mining platform because that's a
mineral thing here we go that's I don't
you want to change blood this is going
counselor orders I want to go over here
I'll remove this turn oh we're totally
into this now is that some sort of a
green phantom it's like I tell you why
it is Oh hack hack you Lin says set the
former's to automate we could do they'll
tend to think stupid [ __ ] right let's
walk into this thing and blow our minds
we found a mysterious monolith Danny my
god investigate leave it alone
police investigate monolith I love how
it became technology of a monolith for
advances oh we got a materials part it
okay let's see if that text is gone
what's gone
Oh call me a hick community that's got
all the difference no that's a good log
that's a contact thing that's how you do
diplomacy all right
yeah the arcane technology of the
monolith did something like Oh No yeah
can you move there no that's land this
is like Pacific Rim is it business now
what's that there's a date it's
brilliant it's pretty good
Idris Elba
we just nice an hour anal probe oh so
it's 21
though so don't make another a new
program do a lot of anals the probe make
any suggestions recreational commons
bonus resources yeah come on Feder we've
gone to got 10 minutes left yeah so just
go past wall don't even this is a small
map and we haven't even met a single
other play I'm sure that if we keep
going southeast we should probably it's
alright
yeah let's send our button line down
here oh that's the end of the matter
oh wow okay oh there's a am resisting is
it yeah
yeah into the unknown to avoid all this
kelp
planting forests excellent way okay
let's do what your man said and then
automate fungus removal always building
a road that's great Micah Romans sodomy
actually don't work but base up more
suddenly than the Romans that's that's
the that's the tagline of us new
civilization oh oh yes yay hi Deirdre
yeah spot ah sexy promise our space this
is where it all pays off ah I've heard
many tales of your exploits as to myself
I remain colonial colonel bernall
Santiago of the Spartans my intentions
is to exercise freely the god-given
right to keep and bear arms all right so
she's America and she's got armed bears
bioscan have the buyers got at the
bottom of that seizing boxing look the
Bartok kind of boxing yeah and then
being in the army and then being in the
60s and being several different people
but like I had always in black and white
yeah because future always it has to be
the past
oh look down here Danny look where might
unsurpassed
oh yeah so we can info we need to
infiltrate her with our button well
that's sort of speech with our spy I
know we've discussed him paranoid
delusion
that's exchanged knowledge I will share
my files on Applied Physics fully
disclose your data on doctrine
flexibility oh I show you my doctrine on
flexibility baby sure why not
scientific theories lasers at the
coherence for the lense to our natural
Siberians the simplicity with which
giggling sensors Daniel
yes we have we've called the colonel
we're pulling rank Danny hey laser
skinship look at this it's really good
that is massive laser all its got to do
you know it's not too so that's to
attack okay I don't know if that
actually helps the innate psychic ones
however we need to rename that reeve on
recon Rover doing a laser but ship
it's the anus just keeping or keeping it
in dipping a simple theme yeah I got it
um yes it's a deal oh hello entering my
force is practically invincible uh-huh
ship is called the ACE say about that
shall we
perhaps you should ask the UN to invoke
sanctions ha ha ha it's like remember
earth remember last [ __ ] with the UN
say how could you have slipped my mind
I had show transmit at once no as you
wish sir I'm a cartoon 5 minutes I
survived as far as a true friendship
what don't know we shouldn't do to your
friendship because we're gonna got 10
minutes left so no basically attack this
person oh yeah it wasn't me so it's fun
this is exhausting could be telling bone
herself your vitamin Terry different
ones I believe we're finished here are
spaced out yes you're saying them are
spaced out recovered we've recovered its
own output oh that's just a map thing so
how can the map got expanded to a week
because we have a raishin ship with them
uh because one of those things one of
those options was to exchange a
technology that we had researched in
exchange for her map oh oh not again how
big is there this place
belongs to another player Colonel
Santiago you can attack an attachment
into it yeah do it it's attack the body
well with our Scout we're gonna die my
own home do you want to do another
attacker yeah let's make a thing oh yeah
attack of the Scout see what happens I
guess we don't need a scout anymore
anyway right do you want to pronounce a
vendetta whoa Ice Cube no way the Scout
won this scares destroy is definitely
playing this uneasy first cemetery
battle yeah eat that Colonel been better
yeah well yeah oh I see right no oh
so we killed their defender but it's
still their city like he hasn't
conquered it yeah so I take if they've
got any naval units alright he's a bit
running like he's running a bit low on
gas burners take risk it shall we yeah
that's a risk of Crais restaurant 8:30
boom 17 energy credits there because it
only has one they only had one
population so we've wiped it off the
face of the map great yeah we just
committed genocide yeah we did but
genocide alright this is awesome bigger
what oh I remember those you could get
like these massive gunships with there
well basically hovercraft they can move
really fast and you could stick loads of
extra stuff on them just destroy cities
yeah so good yeah but I throw put a
throat you're always the most unethical
of us all a sexy you means reckless
right
she saluted us
Oh No toss a know-nothing Percy's gonna
ruthlessly crushes my dear arse fit no
case we can make the use that city now
can we
is that our city no did she built it so
she had another city that's her second
surgery we killed the first city yeah oh
I can kill her Tara format this do that
but we don't have any see fungus slows I
don't know okay could we send a gunship
down there what about our cities can we
turn it so that they make some sort of
gunship thing
I'm guessing well ship it you need land
so we need land things yeah we got one
of those cities to make it is he killing
her with the laser technology she gave
us no I think that's serious I think
that might just be how all of the combat
sounds yeah so what is that input Oh
particle in fact all we've got a really
good gun now I know okay
oh yeah nice Danny we can make that do
it they call me Andy there it's fine I'm
sorry
and these in London yeah he's good yeah
he's making good foes I just a moving
film stars he doesn't do that much is he
he refused hunter yeah one of the
biggest phones at the moment on Sina is
who's the blog Zed - yeah Sony Xperia
ser - yeah great phone and he loved it
review this week yeah it's on the site
now sweet let's go up here yeah do
something
we're in 2037 we've been here for 37
years I guess oh hello what that doesn't
make any sense
oh I have to attack this thing right
we've backed off I do they don't listen
go okay don't really understand what
happened there
can we attack the city with that thing
find out hit him again
he's gonna die isn't okay he keeps
getting hit and then running away what
an idiot who hello our probe team can
subvert and capture the many credits
donut here / yes you do that 70% do it
there yes we do yeah we do so we're
gonna use that to go into the city and
blow the crap out of them
let's kill their own
yeah oh yes this is Grace we're
attacking the city with a hovercraft
what do we want to help from recovered
we discovered C farming I think they had
that on earth but okay oh I see it's
added so if this is like a resource from
kelp fart oh so what I'm doing up here
is building a cow farm and it's already
built in here so if I put a city here
yeah then it will be able to take better
resources from this wheat that's nice
all right there's the rover again how's
the dude yes
all right we're gonna send him towards
the city yeah to die okay so I think
what that's doing is production complete
we got the command center what was the
thing with the good laser it was the
impact rover left yeah yes what base 2
is completely undefended whatever that's
why I build another thing because we may
just kill this with one Rover one guy
you like Darth Vader and a hovercraft
let's go I think you can stack units
okay but you can't do and serve anymore
which people hate do it
it's like bombarding the city but not
actually hurting that's why I send them
and ask everyone else I think the rover
is the only thing oh here we go oh here
we go
yes some bad damage activate sabotage
first we're gonna but that we've data
insight drone riots gage mind-control
Pro what do it let's do sabotage
fighters yeah just things up in there I
have a specific target in mind
yeah I just starting the laser squad
production has been terminated
oh that's cool so we stopped them
building a missions accomplished Oh mmm
they've gone back to junk base do our
best [ __ ] annoying I hope you
discover do some damage
all right oh my god is that my that's
the dude again he's gone all the way
back there what a jerk
[ __ ] him insane we've got a cow farm
that's pretty good
I think I think that's five I think
that's a show we've got five Danny we
got four look hey look how many little
dots we've got on that unbowed bass one
this is so much fun can I just stay here
and play this or there can you give like
my can you give my boss and notes but I
don't have to do any work if you keep
plugging see Nash then we can do this
all day
oh yeah trying to make sure we save them
yeah everyone check out seen it
Oh get out of this escape go thank you
no listen they look up to you yeah I
look up to you
that's an order mr. great I love games a
crash immediately to Destin yeah okay
that's it let's go oh here we go
absinthe Sid Meier's Alpha Centauri
available on gog.com for the low low
price of $5.99 I already own it and
there's an expansion pack that is a
bargain that is a bargain look at that
look at all those guys five gives it a
five and he is right to do so
proxy [ __ ] cosmic Caro Caro and of
course wrists our 87 who named himself
after perhaps the worst genesis
platformer ever made so he knows
something about quality video games
that's right that's it Mehra's Alpha
Centauri thank you very much for joining
us today Nick thank you very much going
on
thank you for having me it was a
pleasure I would have been completely
clueless doing nothing yeah thanks to
you I'm slightly less curious are you
gonna are you gonna carry on playing it
no are you gonna fly are you gonna play
beyond Earth when it comes out yes
definitely excellent I think what I
might do is actually play more sip 5
because between you and Benigno yeah
I've heard that is that was quite the
video games if the problem with it is
now I'll tell you what they the
expansions and
patches that they've done to it it's
made it a fantastic game yeah it's a
really good game man bonito what say you
need all the explained - yeah video was
saying yesterday as well the problem
with these the games are just like Forex
games in general is there such a time
sponge yeah that really needs hell yeah
I'll take up weeks of your life yeah and
I've never been good at that since I
joined the games price of not like I've
stopped dedicating to one game because I
feel like I need to play like a load
yeah which is a bit of a bummer yeah if
you've given up exclusive knowledge yes
for a more general overview so now I am
in a jack of all trades and a master of
none
oh that's sad that's fun I still rocket
Kano so I can quit thank you very much
for running and watching random account
today like nice guys with there's a VOD
version of this will be up on the site
afterwards if you want to watch it again
I'm Jack because I want to watch that
all those butt jokes
we'll be back next week with a different
video game as ever if you have any
suggestions at Danny McGuire on Twitter
and this week's episode of the point
we'll all be up on Friday and it's about
watch dogs and trailers and stuff like
that
you're still working on it yeah but yeah
have a great wedding as day and we'll
see you next week bye